what about scalability in your
architecture how do you how do you
handle that and what are some
considerations that you're looking at in
terms of making sure your application
architecture is set that you can scale
because you guys are
you're not huge right now right but
obviously the goal is to is to be
processing i'm sure um hundreds of
thousands more requests than than you
are and then keep scaling that up
right so it's it's also naturally
partitioned right now where
our simple db store we want it to be
global so we always want all of our
users to be on just one database
to be readily readily available to us on
the other hand
our
since we just we're set up with
retailers we can actually partition
every retailer's data can actually be
completely separated and partitioned
from the other so we could serve traffic
for specific clients on specific servers
with a different database so i'm never
worried about one particular database
having to handle a humongous load
for our for our consumer data i think
my i don't know the internals obviously
of how i didn't build simple db so i
don't know how it works um but you know
i
there's there's always things you can do
for a consumer you could you could
separate out their data and modulo it
according to a certain key so put all
your users that
that end with you know this number on
this particular user data so there are
still ways to partition the user data my
guess is that simpledb probably already
does that and kind of hides that from
the developer having to figure that out
by serving it automatically on separate
servers without you noticing and
labeling the whole thing is just one big
service so you anticipate pushing
simpler dp as far as you possibly can
you're just going to keep throwing users
at it and
if it starts to cry and scream um then
you'll reconsider but right now you
think it's that's probably probably
going to suit your scale um i hope so i
i would definitely go with a key value
store rather than a sql store
um i think that sql has a lot of
overhead because you need to process
queries where you're
you you need to query across it and
build indexes across it and all the
other stuff
and if you want scalability just being
able to store data in different places
and partition it out makes a lot of
sense i mean
at google i didn't we didn't use sql at
all and in our back end
servers anyways for speech recognition
um or even in our web server so
um just not really think used to
thinking of sql as the automatic
database right choice right as i think
most industry does
um what about the the breadth of social
data that you have at your disposal
from say a facebook api
um one of the challenges there is that
that data is always changing right and
facebook is basically changing the
schema behind their
api and adding fields and deleting
fields and probably merging stuff and
whatnot
they're known to do that right right
does that give you a lot of headaches
and problems
no because we didn't choose to store the
social data in a sql
store but it is true if you wanted to
have
we couldn't originally define a user mop
profile um and assume that there would
be these certain fields we'd always have
to be updating our schema and things
like that so um simple dv is really nice
because it doesn't assume
a strict user schema
you can still label parts of it but you
don't have to strictly label it that way
and pre-define it okay
so that that allows us to be really
flexible
so those are a really great complement
to each other um the social data you're
getting from a
not always what you expect facebook api
and
the schema-less format of simpledb